oh Shalom I love you guys thank you for
listening today Esther pitz is on the
podcast we're GNA talk all about all the
things but before that I want to let you
know that I am going on tour this year I
had a child but I'm not giving up my
career despite what the trolls on Reddit
want I'm still at it June 28th 2024 I'm
going to be at the Warner Theater in
Eerie Pennsylvania July 6th I'm going to
be in Las Vegas Nevada at the Mirage
July 14th I'm going to be in Edmonton
Canada at kidsman Park I think this is
the show I'm doing with B bur Cher right
Great Outdoors Festival um I am going to
be adding more tour dates soon all over
the country I'm going to be coming at
you you know what it's funny though you
know that I do those meet and greets
after shows I'm not going to say which
city and which venue but I got the text
uh they won't confirm the show unless
Whitney agrees to not do the meet and
greet from the stage after the show
because this was a city where like a
fight broke out in the audience and they
were like we just can't handle it so I'm
going to keep doing the meet and greets
this year but I think I just need to
bring some of my own security or
something to help with it all I also
have a new special out it's on only fans
TV it's not porn Don't Panic you're you
can watch it at work the porn's not
going to come up you're not going to see
a butthole um unfortunately just go to
of.tv Whitney for my new special it's
called mouthy I think I had RSV during
it so I do have a raspy voice but enjoy
me uh being a terrible
mom hold on sorry I'm turning my uh why
as soon as you have a baby you just go
so Mom so fast what do you mean like
when I send texts I say them out loud as
I type
them as I'm turning off my sound
notifications is your iPhone screen
already like those huge huge letters
that are so embarrassing no but it's my
baby okay well it is my baby
stare at all day I think I've gone up a
font size okay like I wrote out our
stuff today and I went to 16 that's not
small I went to 16 wow like this morning
so Heaven's fast and I'm wearing glasses
yeah which I like it's hot well you know
what's weird I had not worn my glasses
the entire pandemic cuz I was stoned and
I couldn't see any you wore them
sometimes on your show on my talk show I
did cuz I couldn't read the prompter
love you love you mean it I always
forget that you're such a big fan I know
it's really scary when I really let it
all out it's like I need to tone it down
I always forget that you're like a
Whitney coming D have I ruined that by
being your actual friend no not at all
like only actually like there's so much
I am shocked by by being your actual
friend after being obsessed with you for
years like I just pictur but in an
ironic way
what do you mean like were you obsessed
with me in an ironic way no I don't even
know what you mean by that no like when
people that I think are cool and funny
and smart are like I love you I'm like
oh is this like how we like love Britney
Spears I also love I don't know what
you're saying like you have something
wrong with you for sure you know how you
like like someone ironically that's
crazy no like like Shia Twain like I
love IA Twain but like no you love her
you know what I mean I do love her
you're right okay I no definitely not
it's like but was it a what is would you
tell people you liked me or was it like
a like a like a this is you're getting
crazier and crazier with these questions
no I wasn't ashamed to be obsessed with
you no but the surprise is like of
knowing you I remember just being like
she's like a tough girl like I don't
know I just feel like you you I viewed
you as this like Hollywood Starlet and
so I projected onto you what I thought
thought it was a pedophile what I
thought that meant which no not that but
like just you like can do shit like you
can take care of yourself like you clean
up like I remember once I saw you spill
water and then my I would just like
leave the water there and you like
immediately like clean like you just are
like not a pig yeah I didn't realize
that like famous pretty people would be
that way would like clean up for
themselves like oh that's that's
something I'll try so you de thoughted I
wasn't a complete piece of shit yeah and
you're also like and you're like I
thought you were I just thought you were
how else can you be like entitled person
you don't have time to clean up but you
do it's weird where was this at your
house I cleaned up water at my own home
yeah and it shocked me and I'll never
get over it wait why core memory how low
like is the bar it's like when I go to
like venues and stuff when I'm touring
and I'm you know and for me I'm having
like a quiet like you know before I do
shows like I like have to kind of like
power down and like do like energy
economy and people will come up to me
after the shows like that work there and
they'll be like you are the nicest
person we've ever worked with and I'm
like I've literally said Thank you after
everything you did and like hi and
introduce myself what's going on you're
so
like this big celebrity like and pretty
and funny and like H you know have all
this it's just really easy to assume if
you don't know you that it's going to
it's going to not be the way it is what
how are people behaving out there I
don't know and it might be making it all
up like but is this based on like the
Julia Roberts movie where she played a
celebrity or no an assistant to
Katherine Zetta Jones and Katherine
Zetta Jones was like a monster is this
based on like Mommy dearest like where
are we get like I'm just curious where
the bar is coming from well it actually
by the way none of this is even a
negative it's like it makes sense to me
if someone is a superstar and they just
like don't like have the energy or the
time to like clean up water in their own
doile I just need to say like you and I
have known each other for a really long
time and we were childless for many
years great segue we were childless you
can't we managed to get through 5
minutes of talking not about kids and it
was like a bee was in her mouth she had
to let that bee out that is the main
thing when you become pregnant or a mom
is you just it's all you can talk about
but this is crazy that we went so long
not having a
baby 1 this is you're having a baby way
too young if I may this is not it hasn't
been that long you you guys jumped the
gun it was too soon you guys started
feeling empty in your lives and just had
one I I don't even know if you should
keep it frankly I'm I'm eight months
pregnant I brought you there's still
time in California that's actually first
trimester so I do think you should put
it up for adoption um here yes we went I
definitely went long like did you think
I wasn't going to have one at some point
was I thought of as the person that was
just like going to be lonely and sad and
never have a kid it's worse than that I
just never gave that thought you never
thought of me as someone like that like
I just never thought of you or me or any
of our friends it's worse than that as
being sex like like why women I just
never we didn't have female organs it
never crossed my mind that we would take
the time to consider doing this anything
but ourselves Yeah in our careers yeah
and then it's just now I'm like I think
some people become moms like especially
where I like like my family my mom my
sister like that was kind of like they
always knew they wanted that it happened
early you have like a secret sister you
never bring up no I know I'm a I'm an
only child with a sister you yeah I know
everyone
knows like you never bring her up she's
not in any of your stories like from
childhood she's no she's not any photos
in your house like I don't I know she's
eight years older don't know her name no
we're very close don't know her name no
no one does okay is she not want to be
in the Limelight she no I don't think
she does no she we're just so different
it would blow your mind it would blow
your mind do you think you developed in
reaction because here's the thing this
is on topic believe it or not I'm just
going not going on a wild tangent
because I now have one child and I'm
wondering if I need to have two cuz our
only children weird but I what I I this
is also something I think about 24 hours
identify as an only child with a sibling
in a way yeah where I was kind of like
well you have two
siblings I have so many siblings neither
of us know about honestly my dad was a
busy man so I have many siblings my God
and I still picture every time you say
your dad I think of Peter Gallagher on
the show Whitney with like a briefcase
full of lies yes my real dad full of
lies yes Briefcase full of lies should
be the name of my autobiography and I
look at your son and I just I'm like oh
he's going to look like
God willing God willing we can get him
on the WB but yes my it is weird though
also be prepared for your baby to come
out looking like one of your parents my
my baby came out looking exactly like my
dad it was wild really I know it was
weird I mean their faces changed truly
every day how really though yes they
really Chang I mean like most people in
La they have a new face every day maybe
it's just an LA thing but yes his face
is different every day like sometimes
he'll look like his dad sometimes he'll
look like my dad it's nuts I okay wow I
cuz all I want to know is what it does
this baby inside me look like but if
it's changing it'll change it'll change
well they say that in the beginning that
for the first couple months it the baby
looks like the dad right so that the dad
doesn't kill it right or so that people
back then cuz women were just getting
raped so much that no one knew who the
father would be so that they would know
who the father was of the baby but my
friend Nick brought up a really good
point which is like they didn't know
what they looked like back then there
were no there are no mirrors in nature
oh well there are
pawns is that I thought those were like
the original you guys she can't have a
baby I know she can't she does not have
a healthy relationship with are you
telling me that you can see your
reflection in a pond I'm sure that if
you bitch when is the last time you went
to a pond I've never been to one I've
only seen them in cartoons so that may
explain why I feel this way cuz that's
where princess do their makeup and hair
so it must be like oh and ice ice they
they use ice as mirrors are you actually
considering now going the only child
route I look I which I'm advocating for
it's in I'm honestly I'm that way too
cuz I'm kind of going like okay all kids
are a little weird you know what I mean
I think I'm just like looking for
something to go like oh only children
are selfish or self-absorbed self-
involved is that bad no none of those
things are bad but I'm also going you
know this actually not so many people I
could also make the argument people with
two and three siblings you have to you
end up being neglected because the first
two play with each other you know
there's no rules with that kind of stuff
I think for me like my dad was an only
child and then I am his only child so
it's like a lot easier for me to wrap my
head around like this isn't a crazy idea
it's like it's fine but I think I think
that I I apply the way that I parent is
basically just how I have dogs so two
dogs is EAS than oneg they can play with
each and you never have to wor about
them being alone but I don't think two
kids is easier than one kid no my and
again I know nothing I have not had this
baby yet but it just from my
observations okay we're podcasting the
whole point of podcasting is you pretend
you know stuff you don't know stop
telling them what they they already know
we don't know anything you don't have to
qualify like hey guys we're not experts
they're aware and actually am I take it
back I am an expert of observing women
and it does we be as arrogant as the men
and just be like no science like just go
it feels like one baby is manageable and
everyone with two is drowning in babies
yes yes my friend Zoe uh says um I love
this she says having two kids it's like
you're drowning and then someone throws
you a baby oh yeah and I can't swim so
yeah I well like to me all the reasons
to have another one are so ridiculous
I'm like well we only use these onesies
for like two weeks so we should just
have another kid so that the onesie gets
used more we paid 40 bucks for this but
that kind of makes sense to me oh I go
like I finally figured out how to do
this now I need to have one yeah now
that I'm good at it yes that I do see
like the first one's a
wash I do get that I mean I just cannot
do pregnancy again and that's sort of
where I'm at and I'm scared that I'm
going to have the baby and then want
another baby and I don't want to do that
I think before I had the baby I was like
I need to have another one but also if I
can just go back on my only child
comment because I know a lot of siblings
that are two girls or two boys and all
the things that I just accused only
children of being of like self-absorbed
like you know sort of like I'm the
center of the universe they're worse cuz
they had a little sibling they were able
to beat up on and like use as their like
assistant who like adored them and then
they turned into that wait do you know
what I'm saying wa I have not
experienced that that's interesting yeah
you didn't adore your older sister you
won't acknowledge that you I did
actually look up to her and was obsessed
with her which is why I'm probably
obsessed with you because she wouldn't
let me in her room so it's like I'm I
invite you to my house every day yeah
and I I roll in here I'm like I fucking
own this place I own this home um cuz
that's how you you do by eight years
that like if you're it's kind of not a
sibling if you're 18 and your
10-year-old sister is trying to get in
your room she's going to like take a
quaon by accident like that's dangerous
for you to be in there I also was just
like would thought it was funny to like
fart on her boyfriends like it wasn't a
good I know you are like Pig Pen like
does like a little plume of brown smoke
just follow you around were you like a
dirty kid I feel like you were just like
a dirty kid as as much as I was allowed
to be for sure kid dirty is more
comfortable and also in pregnancy my
hair doesn't get greasy as fast so I am
not b
what is your resistance
to basic hygiene it's just so
inconvenient I don't like is this just
what it's like to be loved by a man no
this is before that this has been a
while but okay so here's like the thing
I keep thinking about the only child
version of things for us like we've had
so much life that we were not moms yeah
and we don't want to right we don't want
to like totally say goodbye to that it
we want to like kind of have it all want
to have the baby but still
be us that's that's possible you want to
still lie in your bed all day after you
have the baby you want to continue to be
the grandpa from Charlie in the
Chocolate
Factory it is so funny that I've called
what life are you talking about I've
called you so miserable and like sickly
from bed while pregnant and you're like
the only one that's like Esther this is
how you always are and and I was
like I was like I had not really thought
of that and it really helped
me I mean it it shouldn't it should have
been a rock bottom but I'm glad I could
be helpful to you okay so it's like you
get the clear blue whatever on you just
need a gadget that's not for everything
you need a th you need like I just can't
brush my teeth without my charcoal floss
like you are like such a capitalist
nightmare you're like I cannot make any
decision without Chinese trash telling
me what my body's doing it's so true
like if I'm watching TV and there's a
Taco Bell commercial I'm in the car in
five minutes I'm like I need that now
but um it gives you a little smiley face
and then you know that it's this is a
time where it can work what a creepy
Emoji like I
know like yeah let's go but I definitely
throughout pregnancy I I've turned to
Dave and being like after this things
are going to be different like we have
to be really careful and he's just like
okay with come like what do you mean
with what well so just CU you don't want
to get pregnant again no okay okay so
pregnancy has not been a walk in the
park for you no yeah this has been very
tough on you has it really but okay were
you lying the whole time I wasn't lying
the whole time so I had I'm not saying
an easy pregnancy I a couple things
number one you guys might know more than
us but I had a boy and you had a girl
and this is a real thing there
science wait take I take it back gender
is not real choose your own I'm so sorry
she okay she's on Hulu she has to say
that um no it's it's this is real yes
because there's a lot of shit that's
like old wife's tale and you're like
okay please leave me alone I don't do
astrology but like that this is sorry
I'm not a Wiccan there is science behind
this that if you are pregnant with a
girl it is more likely that you will
experience extreme morning sickness than
if you have a boy because young girl
baby girls they are born with every egg
they will have for their entire
lives like so scary I know I once I
learned that I was like I'm done being
I'm leaving being a human that is so
grow we are animals we're not people
babies are born with every egg they will
have don't what you pedophile scientist
who even found that out what sicko found
that out like I'm over here just like
going through all these like studies
about babies and kids and I'm like
people are sending them to me I'm like
find the person that did this study and
let's put them in the fucking ground
like there's one that's like now um uh
babies taints are getting smaller
because of microplastics and water and
baby's taints were this size for the
past 30 years and now they're getting
smaller I'm like who is the weirdo that
was measuring baby's taints all this
time for no what some cross-sectional
study
that yeah that should not what if they
get bigger or smaller in 40 years we
just need to have some data fuck out of
here that's such a waste of research I
don't like any of these studies because
they were all conducted by sick
pedophiles I agree I definitely agree
that make that all that all of that made
me uncomfortable don't worry you like I
just can't so the the 5,000 babies we
measured their cleavage like
what huh how does I okay just I don't
care that babies are born with every egg
they'll ever have I just care I just
don't like that we know that yeah no I
don't I didn't also there's no way of
knowing that right like what do you how
how do you okay I don't I think
sometimes people who know nothing about
science know more oh it's like intuitive
well cuz you're just like K call you're
just like that's not it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make any sense you're
putting microscopes up baby's vagina
like what do you mean yeah how would you
know but also you know that we have no
way of telling you you're wrong so like
if I'm a scientist I'm over here being
like here's this thing we discovered
like who's going to call you out on it
no one can challenge you I would love to
be your doctor you just be like no no no
this doesn't feel
true like I don't know I just I don't
buy it did you sounds good were you
lying about pregnancy the whole time
just to like fuck with me my main
symptom of being pregnant was I became a
pathological liar no I think for me I
you I think you and I are both
like something I love about our
friendship I'm try I just know you're
hanging by a thread and I feel like I'm
usually like unnecessarily rough with
you because I love you and it's like
funny and I know you can handle it and I
don't mean rough I'm just starting
to like I was talking about Leslie Jones
about this the other day I was like I
think we come off
scary I like that though I know you like
it but not everybody I'll call you and
you'll be like do you want you you
you'll say this thing like do you want
just me to hear you or do you want me to
like help you what is that question you
want me to listen or do you want advice
or do you want me to just support the
decision you've already made right and
I'm all I always say advice yeah like
I'm not there's no reason to waste a
call with you and not get your advice
like that's crazy like that but you're
right it made me realize a lot of people
don't want advice like but also it's
just like I think I'm just trying to be
more self-aware because you know I don't
know maybe when you're in your 20s it's
cuter to be like bitch do this and then
you get older and everyone's like you're
just being a bully or something you know
what I mean I don't know I've read one
YouTube comment don't worry it won't
happen again um but uh but for me like
you and I I I could be more like you
more vulnerable and more like able to
ask for help and more able to admit like
this doesn't feel good I'm uncomfortable
I think I was just so trained as as a
child and not have any needs and be so
self-contained and just like growing up
like playing sports and stuff like you
just couldn't have any sign of weakness
like and for me it doesn't help to to
acknowledge it whereas I think for you
it does help it helps for you to be like
I don't feel good I feel sick I need
help I need to talk to someone whereas I
just like if I feel uncomfortable I will
just pretend that it's not happening and
like not acknowledge it and just try to
like get stronger I mean there was a
moment on one of when you called me and
you were uncomfortable about pregnancy I
remember just is going I don't know es
start you just need to get stronger like
that's the like that's the only way I
know how to say it and you did inspire
me and I still feel like for example
like now I'm at the eight-month position
and I think about seeing you literally
FaceTiming with you the night before
your child was born and you're doing
push-ups and I'm like okay so I can kind
of at least have that mindset in the
back of my head like that's an option
for this because I I spend a lot of time
on pregnancy Reddit and people are
miserable yeah but I think the kind of
people that are going to go here's the
other thing I think that you only are um
uh okay maybe I can't be a scientist
you're only keeping the data of
negativity no one's going out of their
way to be like pregnancy was easy
pregnancy was amazing and if you're the
kind of person that has had a relatively
easy pregnancy or just the mindset to
not complain about it like no everyone
just thinks you're bragging or being an
asshole do you know what I mean so I
think that like everything on social
media everything on the internet you're
only hearing the negative stuff and if
you see 100 negative comments you're
assuming it's everybody was it ever
really hard physically or just anything
like that yes and I wrote everything
down because um these are the things
nobody told that I felt like nobody
prepared me for and then my specific
stuff like nobody told me that your gums
bleed okay my gums were bleeding and
they were very itchy that feels like
absolutely nothing to me that's like
okay big fucking deal bitch like
delete that cut that out of the episode
who gives a shit everyone's gums bleed
bloody gum no by the way no they don't
you piglin wait would you floss your gum
pleas I'm the tough one I'm realizing
yeah I know you are that's the thing is
you are you're a little spark plug as so
I'm not scared of you thank you for not
saying mucus plug did you have that's
the other thing is that we have to
change a lot of these terms around
pregnancy pelvic floor the vag vaginal
ceiling it's just like a lot of
architecture terms mucus plug like it's
all just like such a bummer on top of it
my joints did hurt a lot I'm just
telling you all the things that I didn't
want to I couldn't in the third
trimester complain about anything
because I just didn't want to make it
bigger than it was and for me if I
ignore something I kind of felt that cuz
when I would call you I'd be like how's
the third trimester and you'd like look
like you were about to like moan and
you'd be like it's fine you'd be like
it's totally easy I was like okay I knew
this was like I've been waiting for this
day it's by the way it was this third
trimester was my best though I had the
most energy in the third trimester I
think I'm kind of having that too I was
waiting for that to happen for you too
because I know the first trimester is
the worst you just like have to get
through it somehow I slept through most
of my second I also had a thyroid
condition so my baby just ate my thyroid
they're little vampires that don't care
if we live or die and so I had to go to
thyroid medication that really helped me
okay and then I stopped eating sugar
just cuz I wasn't craving it I don't
know if this is true or not but the
baby's blood type is apparently what
decides what you start craving and I got
lucky and only really wanted like meat
and eggs everything else made me kind of
nauseous so maybe that's why I had
energy cuz I wasn't eating a lot of like
sugar okay okay so joint pain joint pain
what did you do for that it was there's
nothing to do I was just in pain at all
like you get like a rheumatoid in your
hands sometimes and you just like it's
already hard enough to like bend over oh
yeah a lot of pregnant women get carpal
tunnel yes that's exactly so it was like
I it was like you know those claws that
get stuffed animals at carnivals like I
just you like kind of can pick things up
like I know yeah it was just that was
but I started I was exercising and
stretching a ton I would stretch like
three times a day cuz I was like I just
do like which is actually also you start
making relax in which is what makes you
more flexible anyway so if you stretch
now it's not going to be as hard yeah
you know you're going to be like more
bendy the charlie horses were bananas
for me I have that started last last
couple weeks like the calf cramps in the
middle of the night you're just like I
yeah it's shocking and I was like maybe
this is some fucked up way that nature
prepares you for childbirth because
charlie horses were wor I mean a grant
on child birth I was had an epidural but
I was just like I couldn't and I was
like you need to drink water I'm like
well I we all know that's not happening
this is another symptom that is like so
low that I've never even mentioned out
loud cuz it's so meaningless to me what
are your what are your big ones these
are small compared to what just general
malaise and also I would I want to say
that taking magnesium glycinate has
helped with the cramps at night oh good
um just in case anyone can I say
something though and we can cut this out
if you want cuz I went through this too
Bridget fety pointed this out to me if
you are a regular Canabis user yeah and
you
stop you're also going through cannabis
withdrawal in a way I wonder about that
and I don't mean like withdrawal like
you were like some drug addict I just
mean your tolerance for discomfort down
a little bit that's all it is like
things started tasting really sweet to
me like like uh like strawberries were
like really sweet to me it was also it's
like oh like like cannabis like messes
with your taste buds and you know stuff
like that I definitely like could not
turn to coping mechanisms which made
that was probably the hardest part of
this pregnancy is like all these
discomforts and like there's nowhere to
turn like I couldn't even I can't even
like I mean you could just think about
the joy of bringing a child into the
world yeah but come on what what do you
mean that's not real there that's you
don't know that until you experience it
you can't think about it but
um for me it's just like acid reflex why
is there a sour taste in my mouth that
hasn't gone away for seven months like
this is not like that sucks but you know
it was even harder on me during my
pregnancy telling you to take an an acid
and you not doing it I did though I've
started I disagree I literally she'd be
like well I just talked to Rick Glassman
and he told me that I should do this and
I was like the guy the bers guy with no
kids you remember everything I say told
you to do something different so you
took his advice literally she'll be like
well Bobby Lee told me that and he looks
pregnant at all times so I decided than
like for sure so it was like having to
argue with you about doing very basic
things I did start a prescription acid
reflex medic medicine that helped like
the pain of it there's like no in
between with you you either have to do
some natural shit that was made made by
like a like a wizard in Culver City or
prescription there is a Pepsi AC just
straight up ski over CVS Right Aid
Amazon Fresh that shit you it either has
to be like impossibly easy or cost money
I want to hear other things that you
drummed up just to like make it seem
like you're a human being cuz these are
embarrassing I did you look you do also
start to like just stink you've always
again you've always exper your
you've always just smelled like an
aquarium for no reason but that was new
to me to just be like and I think it was
I was bathing a lot I I bathe uh when
I'm pregnant when I'm not pregnant like
this weird OCD thing I do um but I also
was not doing like chemicals of course
like but I just like
stunk uh yeah I don't know if that's
Nature's way of getting men to not rape
us when we're pregnant or something like
repellent thing I don't know
also third trime see I don't want to
psych you out but third trimester I
could not inhale I I I was having
trouble breathing well but at the very
end it was just like I feel like he was
just cuz they just compress your organs
right like everything is smaller your
stomach is Tiny I didn't have a big
appetite in my third trimester too which
made me like very anxious I think most
of my stuff was mental like I had people
say to me a lot I think it's just cuz
I'm tall and I carried well I had a boy
um I have like a big torso but people
would always be like you don't even look
pregnant and I think they meant it as a
compliment I am sure obviously they did
but it made me be like is my baby small
is my baby dead I think something's
wrong with my baby so I was more in like
the mental anxiety I fully have
experienced that too where people say
you don't look pregnant and the first
like six or seven months before I now
feel like I look pregnant I was like my
baby's not growing that's what I was I
don't this is bad but I think someone's
just trying to say you look really cute
people be like from behind you don't
even look pregnant first of all why are
you looking at me from behind like what
are you second like it was just like
that was not helpful to me even though I
know people's hearts were probably in
the right place but I was just like
really stressed out that my baby wasn't
big enough wait I have a like kind of
heavy question for you which so a lot of
times like this was more before I
started taking magnesium to relax but
like I would have these wakeups in the
middle of the night where I would just
be in such a panic of like I waited too
long uh oh my God like family is the
most important thing I can't like I just
get into this weird anxious place and
I'm just curious because you literally
did this like after both of your parents
passed away and how did that did that
make the pregnancy like harder more
emotional like I don't know I'm just
really curious that perspective that's
interesting cuz I think about like
there's something about like when you
lose both parents I think something kind
of cool happen happens like where you're
just instantly an adult in ways that you
just can't be with parents and that
that's not to say that people with
parents are immature but it's like when
your parents alive you're always
someone's kid yeah that's like the only
way I know how to describe it it's just
you're kind of like once parents die
you're like oh like I have to make a
will like you have to do like very adult
shit like no one's going to not that my
parents were ever very like parenting
like I I was a parentified child but
it's like just certain things like that
where you're like you're just the alpha
now and there's just certain shit you
stop doing so it's like I talk a lot
about boundaries and self-respect and
maybe I've been full of shit all this
time it's all stuff that I've wanted to
be able to do effortlessly but I wasn't
able to effortlessly enforce a lot of
these like protocols that we talk about
like the energy dollars and having
boundaries and cutting people off and
like you know say what you mean mean
what you say don't say I mean like
there's just a certain level of maturity
that you instantly it's like having a
software update on your phone or
something it's just like new you just
like see everything very differently um
you don't pity yourself the same way or
play the victim just little things like
that when you're done with a phone call
you get off maybe is that from having
parents pass away or having a baby or
both I think it's from having a baby but
I'm sorry having parents die because
also you've watched people die in front
of you and you have a very like deep
understanding that we're dying like
every day we're just slowly dying okay
like we're we're dying like that's a
great a lot of people don't spend a lot
time thinking about that like when I see
friends in bad relationships and like
doing shit and I'm just like you're
literally dying in this is how you're
choosing to spend your life I actually
think that's such a much more articulate
way of expressing what I'm saying that I
have in the middle of the night while
pregnancy it's like I wake up and I'm
like we're dying like yeah this is I got
to do this cuz there's not a lot of time
so you just decided to have a kid yeah
at8 months pregnant you decided you've
decided this is something you're
committing to well this is another thing
I'm curious about like I was never like
I have to have a kid my whole life but
you know what I'll say I wasn't but then
I had a couple friends point out to me
they were like well you froze your eggs
at 30 like I did all these things that I
didn't really realize I I just I always
knew I was going to have a kid later got
pregnant at 40 and I said to my friend
Genevie like I was like oh my God is
this crazy I got pregnant for like this
is like crazy I got like naturally
pregnant for and she was like Winnie you
always said you were going to do this
and I was like what are you talking
about and she was like I met you when
you were 35 and I asked you about kids
and you were like I'm having a kid at 40
and I was and she's like I thought it
was so weird because I was like you know
so it almost was like all subconscious
yeah she was like you said you were like
I don't know if it's going to be
adoption I don't know if it's going to
be for my frozen eggs or what it is
whether I'm with someone or not I'm
going to have a kid at 40 and she's like
you always said that to me and I guess I
didn't even realize I was saying it but
it was just yeah almost like a
subconscious just like plan but here's
what I didn't want to do I didn't want
to worry about it a second before I was
going to do it I wasn't going to just
like spend a bunch of time being like is
it this guy is it this guy is it now is
it now thank God God cuz that is seems
really thank God I didn't have a baby
with a blue man
what that could have happened if I did
it when I was 34 like a Blue Man Group
yeah okay he was in the group oh my God
he was a backup okay even better he was
what is it called the when you're the
like if the main one gets sick oh yeah
but they have to wear all the
makeup in case one gets hurt they do not
have to wear them no she's in no
Broadway standing don't listen to her
no they're standing there's always four
blue mens in full just praying that one
of them breaks their
ankle tell you I'm telling you the show
must go on Esther I think I know how
Showbiz works you think they're just out
there winging it with four men in makeup
what if one of them falls off a drum
there's no time to get there's no time
you know how long it takes get looks
really hard yeah so they're just there's
four guys that 365 days a year Put on
Full makeup and just sit there waiting
dat wait when I've like studied your
whole history I don't remember this this
is new information there's a couple
there's a couple blind spots even I
won't acknowledge eser okay which is
fair I feel like we all have
ex-boyfriends that count and ones that
don't count yeah I think between the
ones that counted I would always go so
far the direction of like
ridiculous just so that it wasn't like
when I say I would Rebound with people
they were professional athletes they
were literally remers like I would go so
far cuz I was maybe still hung up on the
other person or right didn't want to get
in something
serious okay back
to I think there's like let's just say
I've put a couple men on tape for
auditions what do you
mean what do you mean let's just
say I'm a mother okay I'm you're
disturbing me you young
sluts I am someone's mommy when I look
back I mean you
really gosh like what's the weirdest
like vocation you've ever dated I dated
a
paramedic what yeah which I was like
when he used to be a paramedic and I was
like why did he stop cuz he was a
loser I don't know how do you become a
paramedic and just be like not for me
don't you take a bunch of classes
because it's no it's like being a
paramedic is not like it's not that hard
this makes a lot of sense actually
paramedics are like the chiropractors of
er people huh they are just like guys
who play guitar they're not I think this
is this it's not what you think it's
like how you think when you're little if
you call 911 someone's going to show up
it's not like that uhuh like nobody
comes it's like it's is it like a mall
security guard it's a little bit like
that yeah but how do you know cuz I know
can tell you I wasn't I did have my ear
bitten off and they sent the paramedics
and they did look very overwhelmed and
when and when they saw my ear hanging
off they were like like they they were
all I was like why are you freaked out I
know you guys shouldn't be freaked out
they're just to get you from point A to
B they're Uber drivers yeah yes but
they're more like a degree I'm pretty
sure no it's like a simple training and
then they like no CPR yeah it's very
Uber adjacent it's like my door Dash
driver is probably who showed up for
your ears
okay so let's just cut the shit let's
talk about why my skin looks so amazing
okay is it because the lighting on the
podcast looks like the surface of the
Sun and I'm just a Snowman no silly it's
genu cell skincare natural clean and
free from mineral oil paramin and
harmful chemicals formulated by a
compounding pharmacist it's cruelty-free
I'm obsessed with Gen 90 this it's the
new instant wrinkle treatment from
genucel I've been using it since Dr Drew
told me about it a couple months ago gen
90 instantly reduces the appearance of
wrinkles anywhere you use it I use it
under the eyes on the forehead like the
crow's feet laugh line starts working in
seconds okay that my skin is so tight if
I got murdered by a psychopath of
carnivore and he skinned me alive to
wear me as a skin suit it wouldn't even
fit him gen 90 technology is a game
changer honestly I may put it on my
hoo-ha now that I have given birth so
it's all snatched back life hack I'm
sure they're going to drop me after I
said that but why not it's skin skin is
skin that's my motto in life gen 90 is
on sale now at genucell.com and it's of
course included in the bestseller
package order right now jell GN
c.com Whitney free shipping on all
orders I'm and I'm I look as young as my
baby
and I think that's a healthy
goal all right so let's just talk about
my voluptuous lioness hair I've always
been terrified of losing my hair ever
since watching The Craft when I was a
hot teen it's been kind of a recurring
Nightmare and once I got pregnant I be
it truly became a reality okay that's I
just started balding okay which has
really put a strain on me and my son's
relationship for the first couple days
he was here he was not so much my child
more just the vampire who ate my hair
follicles but we've we've worked through
it haven't we buddy the because like
look the only thing more horrifying than
knowing you're going to give birth is
being pregnant and seeing an entire
guinea pig of your hair matted up in the
drain so gross like hair thinning it why
is it fine when it's on your head and
the second it falls off and gets wet
you're like like that was it on my I was
just carrying that around on my dome for
year like a while the point is hair
thinning in impacts a lot of us thank
God Dr Ben tally actually suggested that
I take neutri no business like I was
taking it before they even started
sponsoring the show and I started taking
it it started working and now when my
friends are like oh my God are you
balding yet from pregnancy and how am I
baby and I'm like no actually I have so
much hair right now I could make tons of
those little Blair Witch Project like
twig bundles and I'd still look like
Rapunzel bitch try nutriful because over
half of us will experience hair thinning
at some point in our lives it's not it's
not only common it's just normal join
the over 1 million people who are doing
something about it with nutrifil hair
thinning is complicated the problem is
it's much bigger than your hair alone
like your skin your hair is a reflection
of your health it's these internal
factors can impact the way your hair
grows and feels and looks and nutrifil
is a whole body approach that
multi-targets underlying root causes
sorry for the pun like stress hormonal
fluctuation nutrient gaps for visibly
thicker stronger hair it's a number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement with 1 million people nailing
it now that they take neutral take the
first step to visibly thicker healthier
hair for a limited time nutrifol is
offering our listeners $10 off your
first month subscription and free
shipping when you go to nutri.com and
enter the promo code good for you find
out why over 4,500 healthc Care
Professionals and stylists recommended
nutriful for healthier hair nutri.com
spelled Nutra n u t r a full fo o.com
promo code good for you that's us
neutral f.com promo code good for you
we're not like humans we're animals and
we're not meant to survive child birth
yeah that's a concern that's like an
important think about that a lot too
sorry just so you know most EMTs work as
EMTs for a couple years to get some
experience some experience uh before
undergoing additional 1,200 to 1,800
hours of training to become a paramedic
they some of them require you to have
worked as an EMT for 6 months so all of
this is more work than you've ever done
in your life on anything that's a lot of
hours yeah I can't count that many hours
so tell me more about that schlub you
dated that loser he was very fit yeah
what was this relationship how did you
meet a quick little like we were both
working as waiters somewhere he was a
paramedic turn waiter yeah you you're
not I feel like you're not keeping up
I'm I think I just think you're wrong I
don't I think you're getting this
backwards I just so maybe it sounds like
he was an EMT why would someone quit
have did you ever ask him about
himself usually you don't have to ask
guys that they'll just tell you I don't
remember honestly maybe I didn't and so
how bad of a waitress were you I oh I'd
love to answer that I didn't make it to
the final round to the table I did not
it was the hard Raw Cafe in Hollywood
that was opening and I did like three
weeks of training where I earned pins
and did flashcards and then like the big
test day came and I was like I can't
memorize this shit I'm G to get by in
personality
memorizing and then meing what like the
menu yeah oh and I never had alcohol so
it's like I'm not going to memorize I
don't know this stuff yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so then it was actually a night
where I had a gig in La Hoya so if it's
someone is like oh I would like to get a
Cosmopolitan what's in that
again the waitress doesn't need to know
that like it's Google it yeah so they
were they were asking too much so I
thought it would be fine and I turned in
my test and she was like this is like
all blank and I was like yeah and she's
like you have to stay in I was like I
got a be show in La Hoya and she's
like okay you've been demoted to guest
and like I never made it to the tables
what's a guest like you can stay here if
you want you can eat at the hotel you're
welcome to come back in as a
customer we're not asking we're not
Banning you from the premises which is
huge admit commit to me now that's
huge I mean there's some debate in the
back but we decided that we'll let you
eat here if you
want that's wild yeah can't picture that
was a just a quicky so tell me what do
you feel like cuz I feel like you've had
I don't know I don't I when my friends
get pregnant they normally just
disappear do you know what I mean this
is the first time in my life that like
I'm pregnant the same time a friend is
pregnant
or like you know as we get so it's like
I honestly haven't usually when my
friends get pregnant they just kind of
disappear and I don't know what happened
when they disappeared cuz I frankly
didn't care to ask I just figured it was
like oh you're pregnant now and why
would you be friends with me anymore and
now I look back and I'm like oh I was
such a bad friend because when I got
pregnant I felt so lonely like instantly
you told me that you were like you
prepared me you were like no one's going
to want to be your friend anymore it's
over and I was like oh that's true yeah
cuz you can't do drugs with anyone
no exactly and they're like when you
can't do drugs with us and you're so
inconvenient and it's like I fully I
think cuz I've gone through this so much
I don't fault anyone it's like it is
this sad weird thing it's like well yeah
I I wouldn't want to be friends with you
if you were going through this
completely life-changing thing and then
I'm not and it seems harder and like you
don't know what to ask you don't know
what to you know what I'm saying it's
like you don't know what to say like
when my friends got pregnant it's just
sort of like how is it like I kind of
care but I kind of also don't know how
to help you solve it and like way of
understanding it at all I just look I'm
like God that must be so hard like don't
you want to just hang out with pregnant
people like isn't that how that works
you just graduate to Mom and like I'll
see you when I catch up like that's
always how I thought it would go and
also like as a pregnant person when
you're pregnant it is hard to talk to
people that haven't been through it
because they're just like talking about
their day and you're just like why do
you who cares it's this is real and I
don't neither of us care about the other
person's day yeah I don't fault anyone I
don't get it my interests have just
become and you're like get away from me
what do you mean because you're like
you're smoking you're wearing
perfume you're vaping you're having fun
you're just yeah like I don't like get I
don't think all this is giving my baby
autism like just you're giving my baby
brain damage yeah also it's like it's
just such a things are really changing
and I'm curious to see what will happen
like if I'll be able to maintain
friendships with people who don't have
children like I should be able to but I
don't see it being like I it's just
seems harder but on the flip side like
now because of you introducing me to
like Rachel Feinstein and then Rosebud
and I like
connected I just feel like oh there's
all these new relationships where it's
instant closeness yeah which is the best
I'm so glad you and Rachel are close
should I tell you how to pronounce your
name now that you're good friends yeah
how so I think it's fine Stein it's when
you're Jewish it doesn't I know okay you
guys can do that for me it's a hate
crime okay should we call her she's in
one of the tunnels does she get do you
think she gets reception in the tunnels
she lives
in but um that's yeah no that's another
big thing like like people it is wild
it's like people that you've been really
close with people do not want to they
don't want me anymore no and I'm like I
actually get it okay but also something
happens I think this especially happened
I think with you where it's like like
the way that we're treated in your
workplace or whatever for us we're
women at The Comedy Store do you know
what I mean it's always like let's see
how far we can push them let's see how
much we can test them let's Haze them
let's whatever punish them or you know
guys do that to guys too it's girls do
it to girl everyone does it to everyone
but you know it's kind of like you're
always kind of being flirted with in a
way by the guys a little teased made fun
of teased made fun of I call that
flirting okay say okay we're just you're
tall and pretty that's the difference
that's all it is you see that
differently than I do
well just cuz I can see it you have to
look up you just don't you can't
physically see it cuz you're a midget
but like um but then you're pregnant and
all of a sudden everyone's like whoa
like she's like an adult yeah and they
don't want to make fun of you they take
you more seriously in a way and then all
of a sudden everyone's like the guys
that used to just like Haze me are now
like do you need anything like do you
need a water like you know like it's
just or they just don't engage with me
at all yeah it's it just it does really
change a lot yeah and
it's yeah I don't know I think you take
yourself more seriously too in a way and
so the energy you give off is different
I actually do I'm not going like hug
everybody I'm not going to like touch
every I'm not going to stop and talk to
everybody and give them whatever they
need for their egos I'm like in for me
that's so real for me that comes from
I'm in so much discomfort like and I
have the excuse now like I don't have to
I just can't yeah I just can't answer
that call I can't I'm not doing it I'm
not resp responding to texts now I'm so
uncomfortable yeah and what are you
doing with to manage your discomfort
like what are you what's your survival
strategy for forcing myself CU for me in
the beginning I just slept yeah I'm not
a sleeper you're not all you're not able
to sleep I sleeping is very hard has
always been hard for me in my whole life
so that's like not a comfort for me but
um trying to go on walks I've started
journaling more than I've ever journaled
in my life like since high school uh we
will be publishing those pages in the
show not end my life before can I ask
you a question I'm so sorry this is like
my Asbergers like what do you write in a
journal okay this is a really good
question I agree because I write in a
journal as if it's going to be published
one day that's the problem and I write
for the masses I'm curious what you
think about this take I have
so I think that I am realizing through
pregnancy this slowly trans transforms
you into being not
selfish and I have spent so many years
of my life as putting myself first for
sure I like it's about me and that that
makes sense like why wouldn't it be um
it doesn't mean like I'm an asshole or a
Jerk It's just like my needs are met
first and then I can be cool and fun for
everyone else um but I've also always
observed my mom and my sister they do
not put themselves first they because
they had you first yeah yes I can see
that and I'm just like damn do women
need to be a little more selfish like
does pregnancy make us so selfless and
that's not I don't like that I don't
even know if it's a man woman thing
necessarily CU I don't see gender but um
I think that like you know it's it's
fascinating because it's like I actually
felt pretty good during pregnancy like
we talked about this like but I my
theory on it it was the the first time I
was ever eating well and taking care of
myself it was the first time I was ever
sleeping the first time I was ever
really like were so different taking
naps when I needed to nap and meditating
and like taking vitamins like the first
time you you put yourself first and took
care of yourself yes yes so I was like
do I just feel good cuz I'm for the
first time in my life like eating like I
should have always eaten and like I was
never and I wasn't on birth control you
know what I mean like there was like so
many things I wasn't like taking
anything to sleep I was like this is
weird and how sad is the way that I took
care of myself before that being
pregnant is the best I've ever felt
still wasn't great but I just think it
was like the first time i' ever I'd been
like eating healthy and like hydrating
and like not drinking a ton of coffee
and I wasn't surrounding myself with
like people that were vampires and I was
saying no to things and I wasn't
overextending myself so I was like so it
was like it's a hard for me to gauge
because I've always taken such bad care
of myself that I don't know if pregnancy
was a step up we are having that is so
the opposite experience that is so
interesting that like two humans can be
so different because like for me I feel
like pregnancy is the first time in my
life where I'm not able to put my mask
on first when the plane is going down
I'm like it's all about what's inside of
me and I'm so uncomfortable and I can't
like but there's no difference between
you and your child and so when you're
quote unquote selfish moving forward
you're being selfish on behalf of your
child because children can't advocate
for themselves so when you're saying
like no we can't do that it's not like
Esther's being AIT it's like no you're
protecting a child whereas like as
adults we don't protect ourselves that's
why it's like when you do the inner
child work you see yourself as a
5-year-old and you eat as a 5-year-old
and you you know do sleep as a
5-year-old and all that kind of am I
making sense yeah so how do you feel now
that you've had the baby do you feel
this like new sense of selflessness or
is that how you've always felt or like
like I don't know I'm just I think my
thing in tell me if I'm not being
self-aware I always wanted to Mother
things it's I had to mother my mother
when I was a kid whether this is like
who I am I'm not saying I'm this
selfless amazing person I think it came
from really like sick thing where it's
like when you grow up in alcoholic home
you have to be a parent very early on
you have to parent yourself you have to
parent your parents I was the person
that was like guys we got to go to
school hey we didn't pack my lunch this
all describes why you clean up the water
spill like in my own home there's
nothing weird about cleaning your own
home I've seen your house you're a
hoarder I don't know what so it's 2020
let's talk about something important
okay let's say you get injured by a
person place or thing
you deserve to get paid not talking
about emotional injury from your exes
I'm talking about actual injury from
stupid idiots who don't know how to
drive or comport themselves in the world
without making a goddamn mess life could
be crazy sometimes and one person's
negligence could result in another
person's settlement if you're in an
accident not calling your lawyer means
you could be leaving serious money on
the table that is my child excuse me
when you're seriously hurt your injury
it could be worth millions don't be a
dumb idiot if you're ever injured you
can check out Morgan and Morgan being a
person is hard hiring Morgan and Morgan
is easy are you grabbing the microphone
little buddy Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury firm they have
over a 100 offices Nationwide and more
than a thousand lawyers are any of them
single and into girls with a newborn let
me know guys with over 20 billion dollar
recovered for over 500,000 clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan it's so
easy guys being a human is hard
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan That's easy if you're ever
injured check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to forthepeople.com
good for you or dial pound law pound
529 from your cell phone that's
forthepeople.com SLG good for you or
pound law 529 like pound law 529 means
law you know what I mean this is a paid
advertisement hey y'all selling a little
or a lot Shopify helps you do your thing
however are you CH Ching are you a
businessman or are you a business man
Shopify is the global Commerce platform
that helps you sell at every stage of
your business from the launch your
online shop stage to the first real life
store stage all the way to the did we
just hit a million orders stage Shopify
is here to help you grow whether you're
selling scented soaps or outdoor outfits
which I think most outfits are outdoor
but you know how people have specific
you know like like ski
trunks Shopify will help you sell your
ski trunks okay everywhere they have an
all-in-one e-commerce platform there's
an in-person POS system so whatever
you're selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less effort thanks to Shopify magic your
AI powered Allstar finally AI does
something good in this world what I love
about Shopify is no matter how big you
want to grow Shopify gives you
everything you need to take control and
take your business to the next level
Shopify powers do you know how much
Shopify powers of all e-commerce in the
US Pat got to be one in 10 at least how
did you know that I've dialed in it's
10% of all e-commerce in the US is
Shopify or did you just read that off
the copy I don't have any copy Pat did
you just lie to our listener this isn't
you're not shooting from the hip right
now I thought this was like off off the
Dome I look I'm just saying Shopify is
the global force behind all kinds of
rothy all birds Brooklyn and and
millions of other entrepreneurs every
size across 175 countries plus shopify's
award-winning help is there to support
your success every step of the way
because businesses that grow grow with
Shopify sign up for a $1 per month trial
period at shopify.com Whitney all
lowercase don't be one of those like
don't yell at me with your letters okay
lower case go to Shopify / Whitney now
to grow your business no matter what
stage you're in shopify.com Whitney do
any of these companies build lens
cleaners I can't even see through the
clam chowder on my
glasses CH
Shopify oh okay so there's these like
footy pajamas you can't get them on a
baby they don't go on a baby so have you
ever tried to put like the mattress
cover on mattress it's like that but
with a thing that could D at any moment
with no skull so the pajamas never fit
over their fingers the fingers get
caught they're crying they're screaming
they're it's cold like it's just like
trying to get their little onesies on
and they have these little legs that are
just like I don't know what's in their
legs I don't know if it's cartilage it's
definitely not bone but you're just like
I'm going to break this little thing and
it is so hard to get it on and then the
the the more the harder it gets the
worse it gets and then you start getting
stressed out the baby starts getting
stressed out and you're just like
there's got to be a better way there's
so many I have I have speeches for my
Shark Tank appearance of my like onesie
line I have solved every problem cuz
there's buttons and then there's buttons
and then they have the fucking audacity
to put like button holes on you know
there are great onesie pajamas that are
just magnets that you can just put them
on and there's no buttons or zipper or
anything and it's just like a little
magnet cuz also nobody tells you that
they're they're born with bow legs yeah
cuz we're little monkeys like they have
these bow legs am I wrong or is this
just my baby no that is true I had never
seen a baby before having one
right the reason was funny I had never
seen a baby I had never held a baby like
I was just all of this was a shock to me
when I saw his like like balls I was
like what they're born with balls like I
thought that was like a later thing like
I thought that just happened like way
later I thought that happened like
during puberty people would say like
their balls dropped I thought they got
balls at like
13 I didn't know babies were I was like
I've had balls inside me for the past 6
months this is like a lot to process
okay so anyway there's just like so many
things that just are so frustrating and
I didn't realize how much I needed
someone to tell me like you're doing a
good job and the baby will never do that
I know that sounds insane and your and
Dave will tell you your mom will tell
you plenty of people will tell you but
it is n not it is also nonstop because
it's sort of like like just get a fanny
pack just you're going to be wearing a
fanny pack for truly the rest of your
life cuz you're just like I need the
pacifier I need the BB cloth Like Pat
got me these I had gotten all these burp
cloths that I thought were like the ones
and then Pat brought me these burp
cloths and I'm like oh Pat I already
have so many burp cloths now I just have
more stuff the ones he got me don't
receive any gifts from anyone that don't
have children okay they're gag gifts
like they're they're joke they're joke
onesies that don't fit any baby like no
spener gifts baby stuff oh that's true
the one thing Dave has purchased is a
Boston Red Sox onesie I'm like
great thanks just like Chinese tra you
know you have to wash all the clothes
before they're ever put on the baby with
baby detergent oh well I do that anyways
for all my stuff so that's where you the
hygiene comes in with you is you wash
your clothes before you wear them you
don't they've been in a warehouse like
like no I don't I I don't shop it
[Music]
Sheen okay no I don't get my clothes
from whatever weird Chinese Trend
fucking monster sorry you're like don't
you want to wash the children's blood
from their fingers off your tube toop no
I don't dress like you to um but that's
like a big one like no one told me how
hard it was to put onesies on and you
have to put like four or five on a day
because they'll like get them wet
they'll spit up on them they'll puke
they'll poop in them like shit like that
and you're just like oh I it took me 40
minutes to get this freaking onesie over
this Baby's ankle and now I have to do
it again I'm struggling it's
well while you're here today and I I
hope in the next month you'll change my
baby a bunch so just you just have to
get used to it and realize that they're
so much more resilient than you think
okay and if they're crying it's not
always cuz you're doing a bad job
because at the beginning when they're
lying on their back they think they're
falling so you cuz they just like don't
have the you know like the inner ear
whatever so it's like you just have to
let them cry you can put something in
their hands so they're holding on to
something but they think they're falling
and you think they're crying because you
suck at putting onesies on and they just
like hate you but they're just you just
have to like let it happen okay you know
it's like little things like that okay
hold on here's another thing have you
prepped your home for the baby to come
well for me it's not about like prepping
for the baby I think it's more prepping
for you once you have the baby this is
another thing nobody told me whereas I
don't know how you're going to have your
baby whether it's a seran section
whether it's natural I was cut I had an
aomy I think most people will either
tear or have an otomy or have a SE the
first week not only do you have a new
baby and all this stuff you are
recovering from major surgery like no
one tells you this concern yeah that's a
concern for oh also you can't walk
upstairs and I was like huh what are you
saying to me yeah like nobody told me
any of this like no one told me that I
wasn't able to walk up a flight of St I
was like well I set up my whole bedroom
with all this stuff and now I can't go
upstairs you know what I mean so it's
like I think you just have to like for
the first week no one told me that I
would have bags of ice just already done
in your freezer like Ziploc bags of ice
so your Dave can just bring you back of
ice you are going to be icing what the
vagina either your crevice or the new
man-made crevice in your stomach that
comes through do you know what I mean
also C-sections are not a game I love
all my girlfriends that has C-sections
but they're like look you can't even see
my scar and I'm like do you want me to
pretend I can't see that I'm happy to
lie to you they're so low though they're
low whatever but I'm just saying they
cut through your your it's a major
surgery and I hate that so much getting
out of bed is hard like doing a situp is
hard yeah this is like like I'm not real
talk like this gives me a lot of anxiety
and I think about it it's really hard to
not think about it all the time that
like I'm eight weeks away from like a
mystery Massacre correct that I'm scared
of and I have no idea what it's going to
be like you leave the
hospital in a wheelchair well that I
like now I'm good and now I'm home it's
always M but I'm just saying they put
you in a wheelchair that's when you're
like oh shit they won't let you walk to
the car cuz your uterus will fall out of
your asshole I'm okay I hear you
like it's not a game dude women used to
die this is by the way all assuming you
survive child oh my God which is the
chances are very small that you will
even survive this is something nobody
tells you so I like really prepared with
having like the baby shamp shoo and the
baby dishwashing detergent and the lip
balms and the this and all the open it
all first so like you're going to get
all your stuff from your registry and
people are going to send you wipes and
they're going to send you take the thing
the sticker off the wipes before you go
to the like get the plastic shit off the
shit before you leave you're not going
to be able to come home and be taking
off plastic off of a bottle and then
opening the top and then taking off that
metal thing and then putting it back
like there's no time for that anymore
you have to just like do it all ahead of
time does that make sense what I'm
saying yeah of course like open the
diaper bag and put the diapers out in
the thing you're not going to be able to
have a baby in one hand and like
hemorrhaging in another hand and like
taking plastic off bottles I really
expect all of these tasks to become
easier when the baby is out of me than
when it's in me no no no no it gets
worse Esther I just this is the easiest
your life will ever be is today can't be
this is the best day of your life I
think I'm going to be a person that
thrives when the baby's out but how
because how I don't in what world
because there's not there's something in
me that I don't have room
for who's G to okay so you're
just
okay you're just you know what you're
just throwing your hands up letting that
one go I stand correct
it okay so everyone who's seven months
pregnant it's all downhill from here you
heard it here first don't prepare this
is as hard as it will get I will
continue reading this list for everyone
else yeah now let's talk about the first
shit you take after you give birth the
first poop you take is worse than child
birth have to be I I got great advice of
taking laxatives dilax I think all
through your third trimester well I I'm
on a great regimen from you already I I
do a suppository every morning the fleet
suppositories are a game changer
literally like my pregnancy is a lot
more comfortable because of those cuz I
was bloated and constipated 24/7 and now
I go every day it is a real it's a
little like what is it it's a little
glycerin Tab tablet that you put in your
tush I don't understand how it works but
it does do you have your um hospital bag
packed of course not I don't have a
hospital bag what are you what are these
questions I have nothing I think don't
bring too much to the hospital like this
is the one place that you actually might
be on to something all you need is like
lip balm your favorite lotion uh uh have
you made a will I would make a will you
do need to make a will I don't just make
like a you could just like handw write
one in your little journal or you can
type one out and just put it out which
is just like to have in
general people like told me this before
it wasn't about dying in child birth
people were just like you're never going
to have time to think about shit like
this again just now is the time so it's
like you're just going to go
like you'll never need it there's if
something happens my dad is going to
have a great time in Vegas and I'm
that's my with all your podcast money
it's all I just or just having here's
the executor of my will it's just a step
in doing an adult thing that you don't
want to have to do that you're never
going to need it's like getting
insurance it's like doing all this
annoying shit that you never had to
before a kid and now you just have to
think that way because now you're a mom
it's just an exercise in doing something
super adult but you fine
don't
next bring to the hospital Chargers also
another thing while you're buying
Chargers put power strips in every room
in your house and like a couple in the
nursery the amount of Chinese garbage
machines you will have to plug in is
shocking it is so shocking you're just
going to need a lot of outlets so get
like two big power strips for the
nursery like diaper War uh not diaper
warmer baby wipe warmer Christina pitsky
told me about this it is a game changer
bottle warmer the number of things you
need to warm I don't know how meth heads
also do this in the woods so you can
also ignore all of this right you have
you did say that to me once like early
in pregnancy you're were like
15-year-olds on crack do this and I was
like that sounds like the better way
yeah I know but also like they're on
crack you know what I mean so I'm sure a
lot of shit fell through the cracks um
okay constipation hospital bag I did
bring Christmas lights they can't be the
ones that plug in to the hospital they
have to be the ones that are battery
operated so you put the batteries in
ahead of time and putting Christmas
lights everywhere the overhead lighting
at the hospital was very annoying to me
yeah no your Christmas lights looked
really like that's something that I want
to do that one I'm doing cuz you want to
like sleep like you might have like
three or four hours just to sleep and
chill and it's either like you're on the
surface of the Sun or pitch black and
that just makes it this in between like
nice Twi like it's just it's nice and
calming do you have a labor
playlist no so I I I need to stop asking
CU now I'm just like shaming you at this
point so here's an idea for a labor
playlist when you make one I got a lot
of submissions from you guys on labor
playlist song ideas that I hadn't even
thought of I thought my playlist was
pretty good um uh Black Hole Sun
Lightning Crashes by live her placenta
falls to the floor
oh do you remember this Jam no but this
just came up on trash Tuesday they they
were talking about it I'm like what is
this this song is back at the zeist I
don't know why but it's really Back In A
Major Way Salt and Pepper Push It Good
is it over Now by Taylor Swift my neck
my back good pitch uh Ready or Not by
the Fuji and hurt by Oliver tree and my
favorite torn by Natalie and bruglia I
do love that songy but I don't love what
you're saying with it okay after having
a newborn what do you have you been
prepared for
that you will get less funny I'm just
saying it I I don't know if it's cuz
you're
like I don't have a lot I don't know if
it's like cuz we're emotionally
fulfilled or like have a purpose in life
all of a sudden you ever just go up
there and have no have zero and just see
what happens um so I do this for a
living um I see standup as a job I take
the audience's time and money seriously
uh no I'm not up there winging it I know
a lot of y'all are out there getting
famous just going out asking people
where they're from making the audience
do the work uh making the audience be
the they paid to see you and you're like
hey why don't you guys talk like I don't
no not
me I don't go up every night and try to
figure out a way where the audience has
to do the show I think that you should
do that I think that you just had a baby
and that I would love to watch you go up
there and have no idea what you're about
to do and I think it would be awesome in
any other field but I get what you're
saying are you allowed to show up to
work and be
like this is a nonsense field of like
where here's what I will say after going
to The Comedy Store this past week a
couple nights and not going up it's just
honestly just as I do think I try too
hard I do think I work too hard I do
think I put way too much effort into
this everyone that attends a bad thing
though that's not a bad thing that you
take your job seriously everyone in the
audience is on
drugs that's all yeah it used to be
alcohol which was like you would feel
like tension and there was some anger
and people would be like yeah like at
least like people were engaged and kind
of energized there was like a Red Bull
and vodka phase where at least the
audience like had a pulse now it's just
like a bunch of girls with feather
earrings like forgiving their ancestors
on Indica watching the show it is the
energy is so
uncomfortable at this point I don't
you're just I don't know what's
happening do you feel that with
audiences there's like a delay in people
laughing um there isn't an electric
energy there's a sleepy energy I don't
know if I pick up on that as much but I
also am only lately during pregnancy
going like Saturday main room where it's
not like that but yeah I know what
you're talking about and like on a
Tuesday in the O that's it's rare that I
like
you know I'm not GNA name names but see
a certain comic and I'm like that
deserved
more like that actually deserved more
usually I'm like that deserved a little
less but okay you know what I mean I'm
like you guys this is I don't know um
maybe they're all nervous because they
know they're going to get called on and
filmed and publicly shamed on someone's
Instagram they're all so scared that
they're about to be like hey asshole and
like blast out and like Tik Tok um okay
uh the first baby poop is black tar mhm
so good advice that I got was as soon as
your baby is born put I just brought
grapes also everything needs to have a
pump from now on every lotion every
shampoo pump no unscrewing No Cap pumps
for everything you use a lot of lotion
huh lot of oils and lotions yeah I I'm
famously ashy we
know you are like you are they
dried why don't what you're not lubing
up over there not once because I'll tell
you why I
my I my weight has fluctuated so much
over the years that my stomach is still
not even stretched bigger than it's been
recently like I'm not I just checked
into camera to be like what I just
looked to the camera for
help like I'm still like it's fine oh I
no I just mean I put lotion on all the
time when I'm pregnant when I'm not
pregnant arms legs elbows I know you do
my mom advocates for this too it's just
I don't need that you okay so you take a
shower and you don't put lotion on after
no why are you having the
craziest reaction to that what you don't
get like itchy no you don't use lotion
no I mean unless I'm jerking someone off
no you use lotion for that you should
use lotion for that you should use oil
but either work no they don't cuz what
if you got to put your mou on there
later and you put a bunch of oil lotion
on
it Jesus Esther wait you don't put any
lotion on your body at all no it's like
this is why you're so
short like this explains a lot this is
why you're uncomfortable need the
comments to sound off if there's any is
is everyone out there lotioning I don't
buy it I just don't buy it but maybe men
don't okay but but is that do you also
not wash your
jeans I don't wear them enough yeah I
was going to say yeah jeans lol I cannot
believe you don't use lotion no oil you
put lotion on your face like
occasionally you wash your face dry it
and then you're done oh you think I wash
my face you don't get you we're like
actually I'm realizing we're not
compatible we are not fucking compatible
each other like at all like the real me
you're not ready don't share values
you're not ready for but aren you like a
beauty influencer no I had a skincare
podcast and honestly like I it kind of
just made me realize that it's all can I
just hold on the level of
arrogance that I'm honestly good for you
there's people that know nothing about
science that have like talk about
science on podcast like fine but just
I'm glad that women have as much
delusional confidence as men these days
we tried a lot of stuff we did you know
we learned a lot and who we me and my
co-host Caroline goldar who you know her
yeah she makes the fish she's fish wife
and she's a TV writer she writes for sex
life a college girl she's the funniest
person I've ever met she's so
amazing um this is just going going from
bad to
worse but um I tried a lot and it
honestly just made me be like I this is
all fake but you don't have to be like
raggedy in I mean you can like I look at
skin you know this as leather because
it's like as a horse girl one of our
best episodes was you like breaking it
all down for everyone yeah um it was
basically it's like you just treat it
like leather so it's like you don't put
it out in the sun after it's wet you
lubricate it no you famously you wake up
in the middle of the night and just oil
your face correct well okay I when I go
to the bathroom in the middle of the
night I have a pump of grapes seed oil
right there and I just put it I reapply
and we've talked about this too it's
like at The Comedy Store back why say
we've talked no one knows
I Love Like Comics always do this by the
way I just love this we'll be like and
I've told this story before everyone's
like we don't care I think this might
have come up on one of our podcasts
together before but like that's why I
say it
you people made fun of you for having a
wet face for many years it was greasy a
greasy face before like you were kind of
an original skin care girly like no one
really understood you were before your
time but people would be like why is she
wet why is her face wet did people say
that a little bit Yeah but I was always
like I love that cuz I knew it was you
were doing I did not understand like
powder back then like I did not have no
this is not a powder issue you were
oiled up no I would put oil on and then
I guess a little
concealer like I had no idea how to put
makeup on I would oil myself put
concealer only under my eye I don't even
think you were doing that cuz this was
like late night where it's like you were
probably rolling out of bed oh it was
just oil yeah you were I would just put
oil on you were oil and just go out into
the world yeah don't rewrite history and
act like you had concealer on I've also
seen you like speaking of hygiene I've
seen you do the most disgusting things
like I've ever seen anyone do like
literally dirty ass hands and you're
just like just put a finger in a
concealer like like in the middle of a
disgusting situation so you are also a
pig
too like so gross like drug addict level
behaviors around
makeup so you are so not like not that
much better than me I know trying is
confusing to you I know it's just like a
foreign concept but like because I have
watched my hands within the last 48
hours I can touch the makeup and put it
on my face if I were you that would be
gross because you do not shower but it
is what goes on with women in their
makeup is unconscionable I mean like I
when you just see a girl like pull out
just a blush brush from their like loose
purse and just put it on their face it
is sickening yeah but when it comes to
under eye makeup it I am pathological
with it but I use one that's wax based
so I can kind of just like move it
around all wait what brand do we need to
uh it's a French brand called La makiage
it's actually
special effects
makeup that a makeup artist used on me
ages ago to make like a
burn and I was like oh this coverage is
like amazing and she's like yeah well
it's not like to wear as makeup and I
was like it's wax I mean my face I'm
covered in wax that is cool though I'm
into that I mean that should be the next
trend on Tik Tok it's like a yeah it's
like a it's like comes in like a a bar
like a like a it's it's not makeup it's
it's cock it's for grouting shower
tiles like my skin eats makeup like eats
it like my pores are big and the like it
just disappears yeah okay I feel like
you're going into a like a pregnancy
hole energy hole um I'm I am F I am
you're fading that's the word fading but
I'm so brain dead I can't even think of
the word fading okay really quick okay
this is something I just want to say
like
in the first I know we kind of set a
version of this like also don't panic
this didn't totally happen to me
sometimes this wave will go over me if
you think really horrific things like I
have been having really wild intrusive
thoughts and I think they serve a
biological purpose like if I'm walking
down the stairs with my baby I will
picture myself falling and like a very
graphically horrific thing happening to
my child's like skull like thank you for
sharing that that I'm I'm dead serious
like thank you for sharing that because
that's probably really that me it's very
vulnerable to share that and I have had
intrusive thoughts like that before as
well and I hear it's worse after
pregnancy so just I'm like genuinely
thank you for saying that like I don't
think you're like a murderer I don't
think you're a psychopath like I think
it's your brain's way of just like
having a nightmare while you're awake
just just to prepare you for like danger
at all times like kind of like I'll pick
up my baby and I'll just like picture
his head hitting the corner of the crib
and it shatter it just gets very graphic
and like you just go like why did I
think that like I don't repeat it a ton
thankfully but I will it by the way it
changes my behavior like I used to wear
these like slippers around my house I'm
like I'm going to wear those slides with
some tread on them you know what I mean
I now wear these slides that are like
have tread on the Bott about those but I
wear when I because I was wearing like
slippers or being Barefoot or walking
around in socks carrying a baby and it
was just kind of like this I'm going to
slip like what am I doing you know but
like those so those intrusive thoughts
did change my behavior and probably
reduce some dumb unnecessary acent you
know what I mean so there okay that's
cool there's like a reason for that even
though it's sounds so it's like don't
beat yourself up like maybe this is just
Nature's Way of making sure you don't do
something sloppy because it's like the
days of just wearing socks around your
house if you have a wooden floor should
just be over if you have a kid like I'll
like put on sneakers just to like walk
around the house now cuz you're going to
be carrying a child right you know what
I'm saying but so it's like when I have
the carrier and I bend over I'll like
picture him doing a back flip out of the
carrier and just being like oh he would
smash his face I would get in the car I
would drive to the like I would just and
then I go through like what I would do
yeah that sounds really difficult and
also I would hate myself for even
thinking that so I'm glad that you're
like saying that I also think that the
first like whatever I'm only almost two
months in I've heard this from other
women too this comes and goes but like I
think everyone was like you're going to
feel a love that you've never F those
are all people that have not felt the
love of an audience before we've felt
love um and it is like there's no true
love than a bunch of drunk strangers who
stumbled Into The Comedy Store at
midnight um who are on so many drugs but
there's times where I'm like it doesn't
really feel like that it just feels like
can we just survive this next hour and I
think I mean I love
you but I'm not like you're not it's not
very Ro rantic in the beginning you know
what I mean is good to hear yeah it's
sort of like I work for you now and if I
don't come back in if you know what I'm
saying cuz it's also it's like that's
why I'm like always like you spend a lot
of time wondering like what's illegal
cuz like you're like I'll like put my
baby on the bed and I just need to like
turn around to like change my underwear
or put on and I'm just like I'm just
going to put him on the bed between
these two pillows like I don't think
he's going to suffocate I'm just going
to like turn around and get some
sweatpants and turn back around like
like do there's times you have to make
judgment calls where you're just like
this might be illegal but I have to do
this real quick and you're just like if
he falls off this bed and like this is
it like it's hard to explain I'm like
this doesn't feel like love this just
feels like a very high stakes like Heist
yeah or something and possible like this
might end in my baby Dy yeah but like
I'm you know I'm it's very it just feels
very intense in a way that I was like
everyone told me this was going to be
like love right I hear that a lot this
is what love actually looks like the
fact that you're just like all you care
about as a child's comfort and safety
and you don't give a shit about anything
else but it wasn't like just like in bed
doting on my child and he's just like
put his finger in my mouth and we're
just like it's but you do have those
moments too CU that's what you share
like on text you'll be like oh my God
I'm in the most amazing that's like 10
seconds out of the day yeah when I take
a picture of it so but I'm I this is
good to hear and I don't want to be
thinking this is going to be some Easy
Loving like I cuz by the time you get to
that calm moment you're so tired and
going like well in 20 minutes we just
have to feed again and the someone has
to clean that bottle and did I clean the
bottle well enough and oh man do you
know what I'm saying and now he's making
a weird noise I've never heard is he
dying is he suffocating like what's that
like why is that a cold like why does he
have crust around his eye like why is
his nose running like you're just kind
of like and then and then their nails
grow like 2 in of day so you're and then
they scratch their own face and you're
just like H like dude my baby scratched
his own face you know cuz like their
nails grow very fast you have to cut
them like every couple days and then it
was the first time I was taking him out
like to just like everyone looked like
look at me like I was like abusing my B
like he had all these scratches on his
face and I was just like I'm not that's
him like he did that to himself and
they're like we have to cut the nails
I'm like like I know I have to cut the
nails like I missed the One Nail you
know and then he'll rub his own eye with
his hand so you have to like wash his
hands because then you got a little eye
infection like it's just like
whack-a-mole okay well this
is this is I got this the last thing
I'll say which is I'm so grateful cuz
whenever you call me for like emotional
attuning I don't think I say enough how
helpful it is to me to be able to talk
to another adult and talk to you whoa
yeah cuz I think the dynamic is kind of
like oh Esther's going to call and
Whitney's going to give her advice but I
never tell you how much that means to me
too that you call whoa I also NE I
really often think to myself like you
could never understand how much you've
done for me like you and I never want
you to like I never want you to really
understand because it you'd be
sick like just the little bits of wisdom
that have helped change the course of my
my life and that it's just I don't
conversation's over but I just know that
is so um nice to say I don't believe
that you've taken one piece of advice
I've ever given you
um the lotion just over shines whatever
I no I just feel like Rick glasman gets
through to you a
little faster quicker more effectively
trash Tuesday also and you have a
podcast with Rick Glassman too now no
that I once I got pregnant came and went
did that come and go yeah just how many
episodes was that maybe like 10 or 15 I
like a limited run me too I like that
you know what else I like trying
something and it doesn't work and then
you move on but I feel like people
watched it you were just like we've it
said everything we need to say yeah and
also was in my first trimester and it
was it was just it was a wild idea yeah
I like that you did but that's still out
there yeah people can see that rck Ander
have a Time nice love you I end these
awkwardly you know that good good good
good don't ride elephants love you love
you mean
[Music]
[Applause]
it